gaming is Big Business will and Chad you
are both massive Gamers nope the recent
release of the astonishing Super Mario
Brothers movie trailer has sparked
outrage from fans of the franchise over
the decision to cast Chris Pratt as the
voice of Mario instead of Charles
martinet who has voiced the character
for the past 30 years as the world's
foremost video game experts you must now
render your opinions on this subject
this is game slimers begins
game slimers game slimers Let's address
a couple of things in this I it called
us the world's foremost video game
experts no that's you don't even play
[ __ ] video games anymore no I I've
talked about this before on the show I
believe but uh 12 years ago now in 2010
I remember it well I got the red ring of
death at that point I was playing
um Grand Theft Auto and Red Dead
Redemption but I had finished the games
so I was just you know running around
[ __ ] riding horses and uh driving
cars in the [ __ ] buildings and [ __ ]
and you know hijacking helicopters and
stuff like that I'm talking about Red
Dead Redemption that's where I was
hijacking helicopters I'm joking of
course yeah dude that's your Western
brother now they're like horses dude
but I decided I got the red ring of
death and I was like [ __ ] it right I
don't want anything else you still game
though yep I just got OverWatch 2 that
came out a week ago or a couple weeks
ago I've been playing that pretty
steadily but I really only do Esports
now
those are the only games that are of
interest to me because I like just the
repetitive like can I play this for 20
or 30 minutes and then kind of break up
my day and come back to it later I find
games that like where you have to play a
long drawn out story that [ __ ] doesn't
appeal to me anymore
anyway
um yeah what Disney was asking about
oh
I got lightheaded Mario yeah Mario dude
who's Chris press so did you see all
this [ __ ] yeah I did people were super
bummed bummed yeah at Chris Pratt
voicing Mario because in the trailer for
Super Mario Brothers the movie he goes
where am I what is this place yeah hey
everybody I'm Chris Pratt
um what am I doing in this Mushroom
Kingdom it literally does not sound like
he's even attempting to do a voice
that's not his own people are super
pissed and it reminds me of uh what
happened with Sonic the Hedgehog and
that trailer came out another beloved
video game character people hated the
[ __ ] Sonic the Hedgehog design he had
like these weird human teeth the
internet went [ __ ] crazy and they
were like this looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] this movie and the studio said we
hear you and they change the whole
[ __ ] design of Sonic I don't know if
this is gonna happen but I feel like
it's reaching a Tipping Point with Mario
Brothers I think martinette is gonna get
the job
well is he still around yeah Okay cool
so you're not going to be able to say AI
I'll duplicate his voice oh they could
do that too well but somebody already
did that somebody took the trailer used
an AI to put in martinet's voice really
yes dude see that's uh it's a me I'm a
Mario yeah that's all it needs to be
yeah I like it that way it's a better
voice I know Lulu it's a much better but
it's also like this idea that these
animated movies have to have big
celebrities as voices right some of them
fine if you're like trying to launch a
new IP like [ __ ] how to tame a dragon
or something do it get your jack blacks
get your whoever's this is a good point
this [ __ ] is a giant IP that existed
before any of these [ __ ] actors you
don't need the actors to sell the movie
the movie sold you're right it's [ __ ]
Mario it already exists the way it is
yeah this was a big mistake uh in my
opinion
because you're right it already exists I
think that you know whatever Hollywood's
like yeah shove this [ __ ] it's
also like Chris Pratt like there's a
million other [ __ ] people that you
could have got that are like more
interesting choices than that I get that
he's like a big movie star and in all
the Marvel movies and stuff but like why
Chris Pratt uh uh Chris Pratt because
Chris Pratt dude well stellan's scar is
going yeah Bill Skarsgard Chris Pratt
um
what
yo who the [ __ ] else would they get if
they're gonna get a bit if you're gonna
okay let's just say for argument's sake
yeah Super Mario Brothers no one had
ever heard of Super Mario Brothers let's
just uh take a page from
whichever movie studio is doing this and
of course look that's a business they
all have Masters to answer too they got
to make that [ __ ] money
uh they that's what it's Show Business
hey you know what I mean yeah dude hey
it's Show Business after all right
there's big you know what I mean yeah
yeah you know what I'm saying it's Show
Business yeah dude yeah it's not just
show hobby so
um uh if Super Mario was a brand new
thing it's like uh Despicable Me you got
Steve Carell yeah tremendous [ __ ]
actor comedic dramatic recognizable
voice and can perform the [ __ ] out of it
that makes sense if you were to start
Super Mario Brothers and in an alternate
universe plane of existence where there
is no Super Mario who would be the voice
of Super Mario don't say uh Hulk Hogan
or Charles perogan
I don't know I mean there's a bunch of
them you would have to have
well you would have to have an Italian
American or I see where you're going
with it where am I going with it well
there's some Italian Americans there are
there are a bunch of Italians and big
name actors who have worked with
Scorsese yet another Italian American
I'm I'm Super Mario
that's my Robert De Niro here's my take
home Robert De Niro impersonation
everybody this impersonation I'm about
to do will work way better on YouTube if
you are listening along you know you're
you're driving here and there you're
doing your job we appreciate you thank
you so much for tuning in to doozy but
this part is just going to be for the
people viewing on YouTube Here's my take
home De Niro ready
so I just made a face
I'm Super Mario
my name is Mario
what is this place
you know I came here
I'm a plumber
I'm a simple plumber I go up and down
tubes and pipes
sometimes as the pipes got a piranha
plant
coming out of it sometimes you have
Koopas you have Goombas you know they're
coming at you got to jump on them you
hit them hit a you know you hit a box
and uh
sometimes I have a you know
sometimes I eat the mushroom
and then I'd get big and um Super Mario
3 I throw fireballs and uh you know
Princess Peach
they've I don't know dude what about her
ah Princess Peach
would be the voice
oh you know who would be the voice of
Princess Peach who I just who is
Everyone's Watching uh are you watching
monster the Jeffrey Dahmer story I
didn't watch it uh you gotta watch it
and one of my favorites from the 90s
Penelope and Miller and Molly Ringwald
isn't it Molly rainbow is that Penelope
and Miller they're both in it they're
both [ __ ] fantastic yeah
and uh Penelope and Miller
she's Princess Peach
milk Princess Peach gonna Molly ring
while the brunette red Bruno have
Princess Peach blonde
all right
who would be Luigi
oh boy
oh boy what is this place I'm Luigi
that's just basically it's just Frank
caliendo's my Al Pacino is Frank
Caliendo yeah uh my old pal on Mad TV 20
years ago as we did we used to do De
Niro Pacino sketches uh there's one in
an ice cream shop you can YouTube that
yeah you don't even have to uh go around
the movie theater watching trailers you
just YouTube it Brothers on the internet
Taran killum friend of the show yeah the
brilliant turn kill em and the brilliant
Frank Caliendo for my money the best
impersonator ever uh he's pretty good
he's the best there's no one he can't do
and he would go oh boy oh boy I'm Luigi
I'm I'm a plumber but I'm not as fat and
I'm and I wear green dude I'm Alex I'm
Luigi Jones
so it's it's Robert De Niro and Alex
Jones
in the new Super Mario Robert De Niro
these people are eating mushrooms yeah
and and
hold on a second dude when Chad does
Alex Jones we call him chalix McMahon
dude because it's equal parts Chad and
Alex Jones and Vince McMahon he's gonna
he's gonna puke she ate too much she ate
she ain't money out of vodka sauce she's
got that Alfredo mixed in with her oh
she's got a Nancy Pelosi's gonna puke
I'm Luigi
I'm chalice I'm Alex McMahon so you got
De Niro you got Alex Jones Andor Frank
Caliendo doing Luigi you got Princess
Peach uh Penelope and Miller classing up
the joint uh the Beautiful the
incredible [ __ ] love penobian Miller
what about Bowser dude the the main
villain that can be Jack Black can
first of all he's doing an incredible
voice yeah he sounds like Bowser I agree
he's trying leave it to Jack Black and I
don't know what the deal with Chris
Pratt was if that was I don't know he's
up against it the [ __ ] guy he's a
movie star he's in he's in all this
incredible yeah I mean he's the big tent
pool he's [ __ ] Chris Pratt yeah so
he's Guardians of the Galaxy he's
Jurassic world well it used to be
Jurassic Park dude that was a different
time bro yeah and and if he's making
um if he's doing
Super Mario you know he's probably got
Executives going we want it wasn't him
he's not walking and going hey guys I
got a pitch for a voice how about this
they're like do Chris Pratt maybe I
don't think it's up to him yeah I could
see it a little bit being like hey guys
I really love this but I don't want to
like do the whole Mario thing you know I
wanna I wanna do something that's a
little more like me you know yeah yeah
you know I just and they're like yeah
give it a try let's see what it sounds
like yeah I you know I I love playing
Mario growing up and then I got my N64
and Mario spoke a little bit and I
always kind of felt like
hey don't you don't have to put so much
spice on it it doesn't have to be you
know such an Italian caricature I just
want to make it a little more real you
know a little closer to exactly my voice
with no affectation yeah so if we could
just see how close we can get to that
and the the executive listening is going
mm-hmm hey uh get Robert De Niro's
people on the line
they got interested Mario
I'm Super Mario now
oh
[Music]
at the end of the game
I've done everything I jumped I went up
the little blocks and jump on the flag
by going to Castle and I go underwater I
swim around I jump over The Lava
I gotta save panopian Miller
and my brother uh Luigi helps me
and uh
you know
nobody uh
he used to be play Mario
3D graphics
people don't care anymore
look at it
people just playing video games there
was Universal CityWalk walking up and
down going into candy shops they got a
Super Mario store at The Universal
CityWalk going to Super Mario store
driving in with your girlfriends mom's
night out getting drunk puking a bunch
of uh you know Bubba Gump Shrimp and
Margarita foam everywhere oh my God so
it's disgusting now not the same as it
was
yeah Super Mario
I'm Super Mario Brothers I'm Super Mario
Brothers
thank you moving on I'm Super Mario I'm
Super Mario Brothers
[Music]
hi I'm Super Mario Brothers I will say
one last point on that whole thing
I find it very interesting that now
audiences have the power through the
internet through their social media
reaction to these trailers when they put
them out if something is [ __ ] off
they can come back with a backlash that
will actually change the [ __ ] media
100 that is fascinating too I don't like
it do it differently
[Music]
do do
please